大家好
歡迎來到原汁咖啡
我是俊元
許多剛接觸到精品咖啡的朋友
在學習手衝咖啡的時候
我們看到很多的網路上的影片
或是各種咖啡師跟我們講的參數各種器材
很多這些變數眼花撩亂不知從而下手
其實我們在學習手衝咖啡的時候
是可以很輕鬆很簡單的
所以我會拍攝一系列的手衝咖啡入門的影片
希望可以帶著手沖咖啡的初學者
我們一步一步的去了解手沖咖啡
那今天我們會先教大家一個最簡單的沖煮方式
讓我們可能沒有接觸過手沖咖啡的朋友
很輕鬆的就可以上手
那我們在沖煮之前我們必須要準備一些器材
那最基本的就是要我們咖啡的濾杯
跟咖啡壺
那其實咖啡的下壺不一定要是專門給咖啡用的
你只要有個沉積的容器就可以了
你一般的茶壺花茶壺甚至馬克杯其實都可以
那我們另外會需要一個注水的器具
那我們建議是有一個專門沖煮咖啡的手沖壺
但是你如果沒有手沖壺的話一樣
你只要有一個可以注水的器具其實就可以了
那在濾杯的選擇上呢
我們會建議先選擇流速比較快的濾杯
那像我今天使用的是Hario V60的濾杯
那Hario V60濾杯它在我們的流速測試裡面算是比較快流速的濾杯
所以大家在選擇濾杯上如果想要知道什麼是流速比較快的濾杯
我們之前有做過蠻多的濾杯流速實測
那你可以去選擇裡面流速速度比較快的濾杯
因為它的好處是它比較不會在衝突的時候去堵塞
那就比較不會有一些苦澀味跑出來
那我們現在準備濾紙
那我們今天使用這個Hario V60的濾杯
它是屬於一個錐形的濾杯
所以我們要搭配的是這個錐形的一個濾紙那它一邊會有這個風口的這個痕跡那我們就順著這個痕跡把它折一條線那折一條線之後呢
像我會習慣在底部
我把它撐開之後呢
在底部稍微捏一下
那這樣子它會稍微固定這個形狀
它比較不會那麼容易回縮回去
那這樣子我們放進去的時候
它可以比較固定住這個形狀
然後呢我們要先準備熱水來淋濕它
沖濾紙的時候我們稍微把它往下壓一點點
你會發現它會陷下去
這個才是濾紙它應該要在的位置
然後我們再把濾紙全部沖濕之後
你會發現它整個都變軟的
變軟之後我們就可以很輕鬆的
用手稍微讓它整個服貼上去
那服貼上去之後你就會發現說
它的下面的肋骨它就呈現出來了
那這樣子我們連在沖煮的時候
這個濾杯它所設計的效果
才能夠把它展現出來
那接下來我們要準備加入咖啡粉
那咖啡粉我們會建議
自己在家裡磨這個咖啡粉
所以磨豆機也是一個非常值得去投資的一個品項
因為現磨的咖啡粉充足起來的咖啡
它的香氣、口感跟風味
效果真的都會比較好
但是如果你真的還沒有磨豆機的話沒關係
你可以在買咖啡豆的時候
請店家先幫你磨好
那你就跟他說你要磨這個手沖的刻度
那如果最好的話
其實我們現在有很多
這個手搖的磨豆機
或者是機器磨豆機
其實入門款
價格都不會太高
咖啡粉加進去之後呢
我們可以輕輕的把它搖平
讓它的咖啡粉是平整的
那我們剛才在沖洗濾質的時候
下午裡面有水
那這個水要記得倒掉
好那接下來我們就要開始沖煮了那我們剛才準備的咖啡粉是15克那我今天使用的電子測呢它有計時的功能
那其實我會建議初學者
他不太需要去做計時
因為其實計時有時候反而會容易去干擾到我們
在觀察咖啡粉的狀況
但是如果你其實想要了解說
你沖煮了時間的話
當然你可以準備一個計時器在旁邊
但是不要邊沖邊看
等到你沖煮完成之後
你可以看一下你的時間
去記錄一下你每次沖煮的
總時速的狀況
那也可以大概了解說
你現在沖煮的情況
不過我會建議大家是
我們沖煮的時候要專注的去觀察
咖啡粉跟水結合的狀況
不要分心去看計時器
那今天我要教大家一個
最簡單的沖煮法
其實就是把水
直接注入濾杯就可以了
那或許大家有聽過悶蒸啊
分段注水啊
很多的沖煮手法可能讓
我們剛接觸手沖咖啡的朋友
聽了會覺得不知該如何下手
所以今天我先用一個最簡單的方式就是
我們剛才是用15克的咖啡粉
那等一下我們就注水
注200克
我們就用這樣的比例
很快速的沖煮出一壺咖啡出來
那我們就來試試看
那我們現在開始沖煮
沖煮的時候呢
我們就是輕輕的注水
那可以慢慢的畫圈
那我們要注意的是
我們在畫圈的時候
不要去碰到濾紙
跟濾紙保持一個距離
我們就穩定的
然後平均的去注水就可以了
好那我們要注意一下電子稱上面的數字它的重量如果達到200克的時候我們就要停止
那我們就讓這些咖啡
跟水充分的去結合
然後讓它全部的都滴漏下去之後
我們再把濾杯移開就可以了
那這樣子的注水方式
其實你可以很輕鬆
而且
你要很專注的去小心
不要讓你的水柱去碰到濾紙就可以
那我們先不用想太多
我們只要緩緩的穩定的注水
把它注到200克
先掌握第一件我們要做的事情就可以了
那我們現在可以看到
它這個咖啡已經滴漏的差不多了
我們就可以把濾杯移開
好 那我們的手沖咖啡就完成了
那我們最後可以再看一下計時器
我們總共花的時間大約是1分30秒
我覺得速度也是非常的快
那我們的咖啡沖煮完成之後呢
我們可以把這個火燒搖一搖
那如果你沖煮的量比較多的時候
你可以用一個
攪拌的湯匙或是木片把它攪拌均勻
因為我們在萃取咖啡的過程當中
它可能這個前後的味道
它並不是一模一樣的
所以我們把它攪拌均勻
可以喝到是一個比較平均的口感
好所以搖一搖之後呢
我們就可以開始來品嘗這一杯咖啡了
我覺得這台手沖咖啡
它並沒有一個標準的答案
我們只是希望透過各種不同的沖煮方式
來去找尋到我們自己最喜歡的那個味道
我們今天先用最簡單的方式
分享給咖啡的初學者
讓大家都先能夠沖出一杯好喝的手沖咖啡
那後續我們還會有更多深入的討論
請大家可以訂閱我們的頻道
我們下次見 掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive